this week's videos are sponsored by hello
freshmore on them after the reaction
people what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch the latest
big movie from Netflix because we missed out on
the bird box hype and we are not missing out on
this hype train I'm telling you that much cuz
we do not want to be left behind for Leave the
World Behind John are you ready for the next
2 and 1 half hours so right couldn't be more
ready G are you ready to get down every single
messaging are you ready to explain the ending to
the audience after we have witnessed it to break
down all of its meanings pair it to whatever book
it's probably based on and break down that
as well I have no idea what we're about to
watch I have not even seen a trailer but boy are
people talking about it so yeah let's do it leave
a like on this video subscribe and click that
notification Bell so you don't get left behind
of the reject world when we have something
here you know why the Subscribe buttons for
guys thank you to prepper for helping us set it
down these highlights also full length Reaction
watch along so you sync up with your own copy
of Leave the World Behind available for our
super sexy rejects those are our patrons and
over there we cover several things exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs included
all right I am ready to explain this movie
to every cuz I'm going to nail it I'm going
to nail this watch guys I know what it's about
[Music] already spooky meaning like Twilight
Zone Vibes planet Earth is that something
coming to our planet it's the star that led the
wise men to Jesus a siren warning us about the
danger I'm about to show you all how smart I am
I couldn't sleep and it has been such a hellish
year for us as you know oh you have no idea what
you're about to get into you are just constantly
anxious about your job because of all the budget
cuts so I went online this morning and I rented
us beautiful house out by the beach budget cuts
at business Corp all of this is going to feel so
minimal I thought I'd get a jump on it look at
the crack crack in the Blue Earth oh yes I fig
if I made the reservation and packed our bags
it would eliminate most of the reasons to say
no where are you escaping from woman I didn't want
to wake the kids so I haven't packed for them yet
but honestly I think they're going to be super
psyched about this it's an interesting symmetry
to the way they're shooting all this I'm down for
little vacay especially with the kids it's like
the Sun and the Moon oh look at it symmetry again
deep when I couldn't fall back asleep this morning
I came over here to watch the sunrise right right
and I saw all these people starting their day with
such tenacity then you had an existential crisis
make something of themselves I felt so lucky to
be a part of that oh we get so caught up in the
immediate moment but now this made me matters
wo trippy shot then I remembered what the world
is actually like and I came to a more accurate
realization like a 70 shot I hate people I love
her I love her one our faces faces so true damn
dude what the Obama produced this so this is
going to be environmental I have an idea for
a motion picture it's like an eye is watching us
and good catch good catch good [Music] catch it's
cool you guys can just like do this yes I like
how chaotic the sound design is here look at that
they're all all in a car but they're all in their
own world friends Julia Roberts had guest started
in episode of Friends too oh maybe it's this one
on the screen it's not oh damn it no she was in
season two John please all right fine don't be
a freaking [__] when the camera's pointed at
us part one of the house is this like a knock
at the cabin kind of movie that's the vibe I'm
getting one of those w TF movies well like family
goes to Vacation get away house but it's like I
heard it was like an apocalyptic film spoiler
I don't know what that means Wi-Fi password
is a Nella the owner must be one of those
cyber security guys the kiss look so happy a
dad the higher you climb the more your
world's going to be turned up upside
down from the reality of the situation yeah
see I get movies what a lovely composition
oh my god with the staircase and
the motion of the camera and her
blocking n that's okay I does know
a ridiculous amount of blue in this
movie yeah is well you know blue
symbolizing you know the normal The
Familiar you know the blue pill if you
will is that the bacon eater oh let's
go oh get out of there I believe they've done
a movie together before pretty woman he was
Richard Gear that's right he did a great job
playing Richard Gear let me tell you they're
not mine relax I bought them I know you like to
sneak a smoke here and there I figured we're on
vacation why not I want you to have a good time
sure it's just just an easy thing to stop doing
y I got another idea for a good time time intimacy
maybe oh man's pent up 15 minutes before they're
begging to go to the beach get to it that's get
to it nice nice guys oh and a and a interpret it
faster joh we're going in a roundabout Circle in
life well and you know he there was a circular
anyway uh they just engaged in I don't want to
say it God you're making us look so stupid just
enjoy the movie is what some comments are saying
you know a circle is kind of like a hole [Music]
and is this going to be an environmental movie
I really don't know I can't tell I mean maybe
although everything's been so Lush thus far but
I like it's like the music choices they have this
like sci-fi undertones throughout yeah look at
that boat so big like Noah's sh oh there you go
two of every person on board it's getting closer
oh yeah she's a be looks like an oil tanker M the
thing is that pollute our Waters [Music] uh-oh all
these swooping angles you okay Rose I think that
ship is heading towards us only the kids be paying
attention gen Z is going to fix it oh my god oh
that is kind of scary actually that's unsettling
yeah up AR come on bud help us back up believe
it already why that's why wow wowe that's a
terrifying shot that is unnerving yeah that really
a terrifying shot white lion Jesu christe wow oo
buddy jeez white lion yeah let her Roar onto that
beach excuse me officer you know what happened
there's been a handful of these groundings up the
coast something to do with the nav system because
we've lost our way the Wi-Fi isn't working I think
the router needs to reset well sorry I can't help
you there you are the tech whiz not I you know the
TV's out too this is my worst nightmare by cutting
off cable TV and the beer supply I can Ure an
honest winners work come here look oh my God slow
down appreciate life Wow should I get my gun yeah
I I feel like someone's going to shoot them it's
a good omen seen dear at least according to meso
American mythology damn well red guy that's the
very last episode of Friends at least they made
it to the finale dude yeah you can die happy
now it don't make it hard and isn't that the
point of my life o Jenga great metaphor for coll
collapsing Society yeah a precariously assembled
apparatus that can topple at any moment her second
book is like an exploration of how media serves as
both an escape which is a contradiction that she
manages to reconcile seems like it's kind of what
this movie is doing oh man meta someone's here
get a bat a bat why would I have a bat because
you're in The Purge yes lock down the house this
is interesting nowadays like a knock at the door
like let me get the bat hello hi I'm so sorry to
bother you in case you didn't [Laughter] know you
must be Amanda you must be Amanda hello Amanda
you you two know each other no we have not had
the pleasure of meet him face to face I'm I'm
GH George he's George that's how it reads in
his email Uncle good Hank see this is why I much
prefer life before the internet cuz we would have
spoken on the phone you recognize my voice and
knowing that this is our house whoa what a crazy
shot what a divide this is your house why are you
being judgmental about it I'm sorry you think we
could come inside oh there's a loaded shot for you
how do they do that shot that was amazing yeah I
understand how strange this must be for you us
turning up like this unannounced we'd have called
you see but uh the phones are out yeah my uh my
phone doesn't seem to have service it's almost as
if we're telling the truth ouch but yes J agree
why are you guys making this so God damn awkward
why don't we sit down and you know talk and
listen to some Bikini Kill children are sleeping
I wouldn't worry too much about them I mean Archie
sleep through the atom bomb foreshadowing yes
he's on the board of the philarmonic he likes to
encourage everyone he knows to take an interest
in classical music oh my God he's this character
out of green book driving back to the city home
then something happen a blackout the lights here
seem to be working pretty good we have a generator
so there was a blackout and you decided to drive
all the way out here these roads they're familiar
I barely even thought about it so when we saw the
lights go I looked at Ruth and said that he would
feel better if we stayed here the implication that
she's suspicious cuz he is a black man yeah this
is way too big and nice a house for him to afford
on his own under the circumstances we we thought
you might understand of course masasa is sukasa
as our casa is sucasa we thought maybe if you let
us stay because again it is like our house what
she's trying to say is we wanted to be somewhere
safe uhhuh we could absolutely refund you your
money you want us to leave it's the middle of
the night my my children are sleeping upstairs
you come in here and talk about refunding our
money I I I think I need to call the company
whoa dude chill we're not saying you should
leave we're saying we should all sleep together
yeah 50% of what you paid you know there's an
in-law suite we stay downstairs downstairs 50%
I think we need 50% I am so Ethan Haw in this
position I be like yeah D 50% man yeah I don't
feel comfortable staying in a house with oh finish
that sentence should have listened to my wife and
had these labeled already yeah you better find the
right one quick though no that's good it makes
you suspicious like did he take the keys yeah
oh yeah check off's gun and check off
M they would cue the audience in that
there's a gun there it's really they
break perspective $1,000 an now for
the night that should cover almost half
of what you're paying for the weekend
$1,000 well you you you think they're lying
me it's a young woman and her father they look
innocent enough they're strangers they introduce
themselves they introduce themselves what if what
if what if the blackout and and and whatever
that's just all part of the story in the boat
going on the beach what if this was all them
what if they did all this to convince us to let
him stay here he had the keys remember so what if
he had the keys maybe he's the handyman she's the
housekeeper the housekeeper always knows where
the stash of money is you're saying some of the
most racist [__] without saying without flat
out saying she seen the help okay she's doing
her part something is happening and I don't trust
them I think they are scared nice people who need
a place to spend whoa is that a security camera
what the hell is this shot yeah yeah you know I
might have a drink haven't touched this one yet
it's all yours oh thank you all right what's in it
exactly that is a heck of a cocktail you should
try this babe I think you dig it I'm about to
knock out I'm drunk already I think I need some
fresh air he got some interesting tattoos I wonder
if they are hers or if they are for the movie
I like this this like acting toward to force
man everyone's so good it's such a good Rhythm
how long have you been here bought it almost 20
years ago now fixed it up about 5 years back had
a great contractor a lot of little details were
his idea whereabouts is your place in the city
we on Park between 81st and 82nd wow you talk
like a cop where's your wife curious if you're
worried about her in the city my wife she's on
a work trip in Morocco her flight is due back
here in the morning actually can I see your ID
whoa yes left my wallet in my C- pocket which
I checked at the symphony said you heard about
the blackout while you were on your way home uh
this is a National Emergency all radio stations
and televisions will cease their programs during
this is The Purge yeah you got 12 hours we're
only talking about a blackout here a blackout is
not nothing it could be something be a symptom
of something bigger like terrorism or a bomb
like the one that you said your son would sleep
through she looks very familiar I think D you
should stay here tonight for $500 more dollars
yes oh no symbolism symbolism what
do we get to do tomorrow there
laundry wowe that's done nice a shitty basement
I mean yeah what a dump we need to get them out
of here we're not going to do that by scaring
them whoa they need to think everything's going
to be okay interesting they would cut this
perspective everything is going to be okay
isn't it oh when it comes time to survival
you just got to be with your own I don't mean
that racially be with your loved ones or chosen
family she was with us don't take it so personal
I don't think I can listen to much more that
snark even if this does turn out to be their
house well there is not one photo on the wall
not one not a wedding picture of the supposed
art dealer wife on the business trip or that
spoiled brat as a baby wolof why didn't you
say anything about what we saw at the beach today
that boat was an oil tanker it's not a boat it's a
yacht oh Cyber attack oh yeah no they
said the naval radar the Curve the Navy
thingy maybe it's not an apocalyptic movie
yeah still be an apocalyptic thing maybe
it's an AI apocalypse I was literally
about to start the friend series finale
but the internet on my iPad still isn't
working this is why you should download
it is there's something wrong with the TV
it's all messed up please fix this I have
incredible anxiety about how they're going
to wrap up the show it's a vacation dad said
on vacation we can have as much screen
time as we want well I did not say that
clay look look you think those black people
programm this on my phone I was just there there
were four news alerts two about the blackout and
one that said hackers were behind the power outage
maybe they hack the cell network is is that a
question I'll go to the store buy a newspaper
find someone who knows more than we do I will take
care of this FR us his hair looks great still yeah
he got a great Bed Head he going out into the
quiet place whose car is that looks expensive
let's get some breakfast oh damn it they are rich
philarmonic types dad can you fix it yeah see no
it's is it's not working I'm aware I'm going to go
to the store later and maybe I can find something
that you know help you get one of those uh some
rabbit ears or something it's like watching a play
yeah 1 2 3 4 5 six there's just enough chairs
for everyone to sit at dude it's like it was
planned oh my there's more deer than before
they're just waiting to take back the Earth
you can pet them they won't bite you or anything
bond with nature you're going to be totally safe
dude if you keep your feet on the grass for
20 minutes it'll make you feel like crazy good
and [Music] stuff [Music] wowe wow you're
a weird kid yep maybe she can communicate
with [Music] them 96 what does that mean oh it's
radio station John tell me that about the numbers
what is the symbolism of well they're facing away
from each other and so it it symbolizes uh a rift
in ideology division people pitted against one
another or people back to back facing out brevity
is a soul witch yeaha hackers mhm where are the
power plants in New York City why are you asking
about power plants cuz the power went out you
remember that thing that happened in Jersey a
few years back it nearly caused a meltdown what
the hell is she talking about the thing if it's
okay with you I would like to keep what's going
on between the adults the kids like the pool I'm
just going to encourage them to do that until
we know more I don't want to scare anyone but
I disagree with you disagree with me about what I
don't think this is nothing what is it that you do
I'm in advertising on the client side a manage
relationship this little girl takes command of
the scene man where's clay he went to the store to
get a newspaper or try to find someone to talk to
to see if they know what's going on Kevin Bacon
oh yeah Kevin Bacon thought I'd go over to our
neighbor's house the hugley you often see no one
here around this time but I'll drive over anyway
and check before you go you might want to hear
about the alerts alerts oh news alerts on my phone
this morning two of them were about the blackout
but then there was one that said something about
maybe hackers were behind it is he behind it in
some way I don't know trying to figure out what
it means when this camera starts looking down at
everybody I'm sure this will turn out to be a big
nothing like that love you bug this feels very
Twilight zoning what's a love you bug there's a
computer worm spread throughout the internet back
in 2000 people would get an email with the subject
line that read I love you if you clicked on the
attachment it would send it to all your contacts
oh cool turns out it was just two teenagers
in the Philippines poo Pride baby hey I mean
still pretty consequential and what message did
that just send to her I think I'll go Rush Arie
along I mean he's trying to minimize the Fear
Factor to get them out and she's trying to
scare them into getting out I'm worried about Mom
you think her flight is going to be okay nah sure
matter of fact I bet she's been redirected to
some airport in Ohio what a transition through
that glass she's probably cursing out every
customer service rep till they put on a plane
all how do they yeah these Reflections are
wild were they just in the house yeah they
went out did a really sneaky pan through the
window there and then they added the glass
back man this over Reliance on
technology dude you're going to
crash into the beach with a GPS like that
you're going to crash into like 47 deer
yeah the hu sleep
send them all as a
text h okay well I believe this really
is his house though at least I love how
there's like the composed music is in such
star contradiction with its soundtracks
yeah you know hi what are you looking at get
they're just lurking behind the shrubs oh
interesting a dark horse not a p I need to
look up what a deer and a horse symbolizes
[__] someone in this situation is a bit
of a Dark Horse it's too deep it's too deep
for me now from the ongoing Cyber attack
has led to a catastrophic environmental
disaster in the South impacting animal
Migration pattern 1619 is that a number
six and nine keep coming back yeah I'm like
where 1619 where exactly are we in history
US history I will figure you out movie is
challenge I will leave smart smarter than
you ref reflection Reflections constant theme
Reflections constantly with the pose of the upside
down wowe I mean it was just from the wind some
of that stuff that to a throne there's a breaking
definitely a breaking Arie I saw something
this morning dear there everywh dumbass this
was different like they were trying to tell us
something let's see what else is out there yeah
maybe there's like an army of hedgehogs hello
anyone home it's GH I let myself in squelch
intensifies a well if they introduce themselves
they're not a stranger anymore that's right
hello oh good where have we
transition to with these deep
in the heart of the forest they were
just at the pool a second there just
unincorporated land on the
edge of this like pristine
estate oh is he getting like all the guns together
all right okay all right that was racist John I'm
sorry sat [Music] phone satellites are out too
there's a cyber hack we saw at the beginning
of this part two that the satellite was falling
asleep turned a little bit that means oh my God
off he's wearing his obey shirt dude symbols
maybe it's just where he sleeps though where
he hides at night oh who never made that
impression dude you found Bigfoot's [Music]
Hut
oh the geography of this is fascinatingly
framed man I love the music though oh
yeah feels kind of tribal no no I I
don't have any service either I uh
something red everyone who speaks
Spanish probably knows what the
whole movie is about now I know
but just laid out the entire
movie oh my god dude oh my God step on the gas
pedal faster oh God the look on his F just fixed
still motionless that language barrier we can't
help we fear the unknown John that's true God
these window wipes man jeez I know they wasted so
much money on getting these shots done I'm like
this is probably a surprisingly High CG Budget on
this movie isn't that the room you are sleeping in
ew the
fudge yep that is an arm on there oh whoa
awesome my god wow what a crazy shot dude these
locked off shots though W and I love how it's
still at a distance yeah that's so creepy
that is unnerving saw the watch but didn't
see the dead bodies oh my God these [Music]
images oh the plane did crash don't tell me
your wife was on that [Music] plane feel like
I'm watching Revelations yeah why are some of
these bodies like naked this morning I saw
deer 100 maybe more right in the backyard if
you're so worried about it why don't you just
ask Mom and Dad no one cares what I say shut
up shut up
Meg oh my God yo people need to
stop going to the beach in this
yeah wao it's like North by Northwest wow
wow holy go what a shot what a shot oh
your daughter watches that show every
human watches are we are we about to
criticize so much I could take careful what
you say next don't get me wrong I watched it
too it's almost nostalgic for a time that never
existed you know that's kind of a fair point yeah
I'll give you that it's a fantasy you want to
bet the last line of this movie is going to be
where tell you what I mean by that later little
no bad you got a parasite now boy it's the ruins
feel like we're watching The Book of Revelations
you going to tell us why you're soaking what tell
them what you saw I fell into the pool you fell
into the pool why why hide the information you
mind going to my study and getting me something
to wear afraid this is only change of clothes I
had downstairs oh he's going to protect her from
the information I knew something was coming what
do you mean the Dow was up in my line of work you
have to understand the patterns that govern the
world you have to learn how to read the curve
that's part two the title it's been as long as
I have doing it it can help you see the future
it holds steady promises Harmony also lates a
lot of money why are you telling me this did your
neighbor say something to you no he wasn't home he
has a satellite phone I thought could help us it
didn't work even though it had enough juice now
the whole point of a satellite phone is that you
always to have a signal if you have a clear view
of the sky which I did oh boy only reason why it
wouldn't work is if our satellites got knocked
out of commission spooky don't you think you're
maybe getting a little carried away I mean maybe
you just didn't use the phone right I saw a plain
nose dive out of the sky into the ocean thank you
yeah D pan over to the guy at the piano what the
apocalypse just happening around them wowe whoa
dude from
W yeah buddy I bet we ain't going to find out
jack [__] about what causes yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's just going to end with them all lined
up looking at something we don't see what it is
whoa the the subtle use of image stabilizers
in this is wild too yeah the way they mess
with the frame rates and way like like
this kind of slow motion is great yeah
great shaky can that's awesome one it's
like the shake to her footsteps yes oh
yeah what noise noise noise noise noise I mean
whoever's causing this is stripping us away from
our resources that we primarily rely on which is
all this electronically should have covered my
ears sooner now my head feels weird oh was it a
um like a a plane breaking the sound barrier or
whatever that planes don't usually break the
sound barrier the Concord doesn't fly anymore
maybe it was a plane that we don't know about
maybe it was UFOs why don't you go cuddle up in
Mommy's bed and read that book deck out you read
when I have friends looming over me so when her
daughter watches that season 2 episode of Friends
when Julia Roberts yeah was seducing CH it's also
in the oceans 12 Universe Julia Roberts just
exists independently of all these other women
who look like jul Roberts since you're the one
with the crystal ball was that a bomb a missile
I don't know anything for certain yet you seem
pretty certain a minute ago with your haunting
cqu yep fair point we wait for clay to come back
and we see what he's learned or we should fill
the bathtubs full of water or is there enough
batteries and Tyle and food and straw that makes
it safe to drink dirty water I think we shouldn't
do anything until Klay comes back what if he's
not coming back whoa I thought she was being
sarcastic yeah tell me what you're thinking
there's the blackout and then you see the planes
crashing and I think Mersa Le's trying to tell
us that we're not really going to get our answer
what happens next in that sequence everything I
know I have told you I haven't believed you since
you walked through that front door I wonder what
it is about us that makes you so mistrustful
you know what you're talking about don't you
well ain't that the pot calling the kettle black
roof oh what is she implying I just couldn't tell
you when if you find out then let me know he knew
at the market in town yesterday there was a guy
in the parking lot he bought cases of water and
canned goods oh yeah I would love that's Kevin
Bacon's only screen time yeah that's it just the
harbinger and he had 10 slabs apple wood smoked
bacon he a beard guy wearing an old Cowboy's Hat
oh yes he was wearing a Cowboy's Hat that's Danny
he's the contractor I was telling you about oh is
he the one worked on this house yeah he made all
the cool Deets what happened did you get to town
uh I didn't get far I you know and then I just
started to drive and then I heard that noise
and and I I came right back does it wipe the
memory still running water I did see something
I it was this huge drone you know up flying in
the middle of nowhere dropping off thousand sets
of these I I no idea what it says oh boy oh oh
no God I really got to learn another language
death to America ug no kids come in handy I
don't know what the rest of this means but but
this part it definitely means death to America
I remember from a game I was playing oh good was
it a Call of Duty I make that first right this
a straight shot to the expressway with what we
know the city would be the worst place for you
to go we're not going to the city we're going
to my sister's in Jersey Jersey is even better
you have to drive through the city but to be
clear I make a right yeah it's exactly like
how you got here but listen to me please I love
how at first I wanted to get rid of them yeah
and now he's like no you should stay yeah I
I really appreciate you taking care of us I
do we have to do what's right for our family
oh my God this is in everyone's best interest
your funeral because you're black yes you really
should have told me what you saw but I'm certain
your mother's plane wouldn't be flying over
over here it wasn't the same airline that's
why he wasn't saying so okay yeah dude is she
gone I just told you it wasn't even the same
airline yeah but does it feel like she's gone
do you have special ESP Powers I bet we never
get that answer I would bet that you're correct
Sirens I thought you were napping honey no I can't
why not cuz of the sirens I don't think it's a
terrorist attack no it's something greater than
that oh those look like a lot of
the same car a lot of Teslas up
here this segment of the
film was brought to you part
by the electric cars yeah you can't just throw
electric cars at the problem and expect them to
fix it they just all auto drove here self-driving
baby we're all brand new who hey someone's coming
in a white Tesla no one's actually drove the cars
that is selfing oh my God they did all just drive
here but it has automatic you know
obstruction detection one would hope
but clearly not get right now oh
taking the wheel Julia Take the
Wheel should we flag them down maybe they
know something there's no one in that car
W Jes shot holy [__] this is like Elon
must wet dream yeah let's get some cyber
trucks in there wa who Jesus at
least we know the Teslas work
yes wow you ain't getting in know City it's
like a painting right there that was gorgeous
shot self that a short chapter yeah it is
biblical the flood cometh one of the fears
of the self-driving car you said all those
cars came off the lot they did that to every
dealership the main roads are most likely clogged
up that is clever we stay here till we know more
if they are terrorists these are very smart
terrorists we're probably in the middle of
a war zone people we know are likely dead like
your mom m in the plane she was probably in the
plane Ruth we can't sit here and do nothing
we need to go somewhere he try a in it's too
dangerous he's haunted by the fact that he let
that woman die but is that all he's haunted
[Music] by dude she's going to die not having
seen the end of friends filling up the tub t not
really that's like marijuana they got different
kinds now like fruit flavors like marijuana
don't mind if I do I always thought of myself
as a sophisticated man someone who had seen the
world for what it was I have never seen anything
like this I mean okay look I get it Humanity the
way have we have taken over the Earth has has
destroyed so much of how things naturally work
driven animals out of their take your line of
work for example trying to keep up with this
while giving commentary same that is most basic
my work is and always has been about people feel
real sorry for you then why is that cuz you ha
people are terrible look at the way I treated
you and that makes it okay I am sorry for
what I said did thought doesn't matter
some of my smartest clients lost a lot of
money because they base their choices on
preconceived beliefs instead of truth that's
why I always say deals if you're a black
man the quiet is so noisy yeah that's
a line found it hard to sleep not like
at home where you hear everything
Sirens traffic people living by
the freeway can be comforting I pull up
the sounds of honking on YouTube to fall
[Laughter] asleep I am starting to like
you I'm seeing past your skin color and
now if you'll excuse me I'm going top off my
light what yesterday before the symphony my
friend calls me up and wants me to move
around some of his money oh no and as
we're getting off the phone I asked if he to
grab a drink he tells me he's going away for
a while you hanging with you evil cabal
this weekend thought that was only during
the winter solstice pagans that he doesn't
laugh and he always laughs even with bad
jokes take care yourself almost as if you
felt sorry for me you go ahead and die are
you thinking that you're friend is somehow
behind what's happening here or he knew he
just knew especially when the truth is much
scarier what is the truth no one is in control
yeah he's just getting out of Dodge no one is
pulling the strings sure there are those like
my friend it's all just collaps in on itself
who might have the right kind of access to the
right kind of information but when events like
this happen in the world the best even the most
powerful people can hope for is a heads up oh
yeah it's Jenga he that is always the push pull
I'm feeling is either either somebody's deeply in
control or nobody is in control it's the only way
these stupid things can all happen in our world
I'm never going to find out what happens to Ross
and Rachel am I you're still on this [__]
I'll tell you exactly what happens why do you
care so much about that show anyway they make
me happy I want need that right now don't you
if there's any hope left in this world we'll at
least find out how things turn out for them I'm
sure someone in your house has seen it the
way things are going you're not going to see
that show ever again so if I were you I'd find
something else to care about Big Brother of the
year I got lost today what do you mean you got
lost I thought I knew where I was going but then
there were all these streets that didn't have any
signs anywhere you know I turned around and then
I got just completely lost I I have no idea
how I found my way back here to be honest but
I did see someone uhoh it's going to confess to
her a woman on the road she waved me down she's
speaking Spanish she needed help and I left her
she have Vaped yeah truth comes out in the end I
really do I mean even if it is like an invasion
an invasion well or an occupation okay dude you
know what your word choices are like freaking
me the out oh who who who it's the lady from the
road
all the birds migration flamingos you want to
listen to Jazz sure why not uh cuz I thought we
were going to have some fun Jazz can be fun now
this looks like something a lady can properly
dance to oh come on that's not what I brought
you in here for I Love This Thread I wonder
if she could tell I'm hard right now ooo oh my my
God it's like that movie she just did with George
Clooney Julie Robert dances like me they
wanted to get memed did like that's the
key to success how do we get memd if we can
make yeah get a gift out there we're drunk we
are oh we're married I'm married you have
a wife shead I really miss her you'll see
her again no oh no she it was her plane
must have been but if something happened
to her too I don't think I could live it
myself nothing is going to happen to Ruth
I promise she's riding a flamingo there is no
going back to normal don't say that we have to
what no not the
screen he's got fever is he okay he's a little
warm but I think he'll be fine I keep thinking
about one westwing episode there's this story
someone tells the president you watched The
West Wing the story was about a man who lived by
the river in a van down by the river he hears on
the radio that the river is going to flood
the town and everyone should leave but the
man doesn't go anywhere because knows that God
loves him and will say him but then the flood
actually happens helicopter comes flying by the
pilot lowers a ladder but the man tells him he
isn't going anywhere after that the man drowns
in the flood and so he goes up to heaven and
he's really angry at God this all happened in
the westwing I pray to you every day I thought
you loved me why didn't you save me and God says
I sent you a radio report yeah pay attention to
the signs and a helicopter what more do you want
what's this about Rose this situation I think I'm
done waiting I'm I'm going to find a DVD of
friends physical media is the only way it's
just us now isn't it the [__] goes down do you
trust these people that are in our house a that
boy was sneaking pictures of Me by the pool
that little girl keeps staring into the woods
like Donnie Darko and I'm pretty sure the husband
wants to me hell yeah he's not actually going to
do anything he's not that guy but did he want
to Absol lutely my point remains I don't trust
them Discerning jeez I'm not going to let anything
happen to you if that's what you're asking she's
so observant I'm asking for you to remember that
if the World falls apart trust should not be DED
out easily to anyone especially white people fair
just what exactly was the point of letting them
back into the house was the right thing to do
and that right there what going to in the end
yeah oh stri that's cool you're watching like the
process of what leads to the survival instincts in
an apocalypse you know totally normally you kind
of just skip to and this is like what Humanity
has come you're watching In This Very isolated
situation the evolution of it where's Rosie I
don't know she got up before us I'm going to go
look around she get up she's going to check all
the neighboring houses for DVDs oh you're not
so warm now really cold does your throat hurt
oh no good oh he's a zombie his leg's falling off
what the is that blood I don't want what what is
happening what are you doing oh my God e glue
it back in like the flash why are you so casual
about this oh God ew ew ew ew e ew God with the
roots my teeth yeah something's wrong with Archie
what is it oh the exactly what I said uh my my
my teeth just they feel weird and I and I oh
know not okay not okay not okay one wait were
we in a part four already I guess we were what
was part four uh the the water oh yeah I right
part three was short yeah yeah that's right a
bug bit me yesterday in the woods that must be it
then probably just a tick lime disease I've seen
stranger symptoms Stranger Than This and we need
to go to the hospital there ain't no hospital the
expressway is the only way out of town besides if
the road are jam don't want to be there to help us
anyway well we have to do something Archie needs
to see a doctor put your hands on her I'm telling
you I have looked everywhere and she's not here
she's not down there she behind the painting she
wasn't outside but I think she may have taken
one of the bikes from the garage a blockbuster
she she saw some deer and she wanted to go look
for them so maybe there I don't know I'm going
wor St to cover your ankles oh my God I'm coming
with you no it's not safe you cannot leave me here
by myself he's sick Bo don't you see that Dad
you will never come back a set a timer 1 hour
I'll be back actually doing it too that's good
I'll be back for you before this goes off oh
boy that means we have exactly one hour left
in this movie oh Jesus a long movie I was so
into it until you told me I was damn got to
watch more of this now [__] hour this is
it's got yeah swirl to it almost it's like
a spiral it's like Uzumaki but what does it
mean I want to know what the is the plan I want
to know that we can find my kid and then get in
youring expensive car and drive to an actual
hospital and then we can just all go back to
our house yeah well what if that's not possible
yeah you don't care that I'm here and my mom is
probably at the bottom of some ocean I don't have
anyone else I have nothing to go home to but them
do you do you understand that a I care I do I
don't know what I'm supposed to do about that
but I do care Huggers some what do you get out
of being so angry all the time protection from
her actual feelings no people just suck and she
gets to stay away from them my whole job is to
understand people well enough so that I know
how to lie to them so I can sell them things
they don't really want cool when you really see
the way they treat each other well you see what
they do and they do it without even thinking about
it you have to kind of just see the wors in people
I think deep down we know we're not fooling anyone
deep down no it's pretty obvious and agreed upon
mass delusion to help us ignore and keep ignoring
how awful we really are absolutely I completely
agree with the sentiment here here that's why I
buy beyond meat fixing the problem oh whoa the
deer she Now commands the deer yes she's going to
come out riding them sorry to bother you at home
like this I'm going to need you and your comrade
to step off the porch and stand by your vehicle
your comrade off the porch and buy your vehicle
man Kevin Bacon and Julia Roberts used to be such
nice bading actors now they're playing [__]
racists what can I do for you just checking on
you if you heard anything about what's going on
yeah I'm clay my family ran at gh's George just
at home we're from the city oh no well we came out
here because my son needs help uh he's vomiting
he's he's lost his teeth and they just fell out
can't explain it thank you well it's got to have
something to do with that noise you know something
about the noise it's not all that the similar to
what happened in Cuba while back microwave weapons
they call it produces a kind of radiation that can
be beamed out through sound what something is a
foot now what that is exactly I don't know maybe
this is as much as we're ever going to know maybe
we just need need to sit tight pray whatever works
for you I'm going to watch the Cowboys like clay
said his son isn't well we're going to need more
than just prayers knowing how primed you are for
these kind of situations we're thinking you might
have some medicine that'll be able to help you
what I got isn't your business survivalism you
telling this man not to take care of his son
nothing makes a whole lot of sense right now
when the world doesn't make any sense I can still
do what's rational which is protect my own yeah
that's what I was saying earlier you got to stick
to your own of course and I meant not as a racist
thing yeah yeah my son's really sick he needs your
help he's 16 years old dude Ethan Hawk is such a
good actor oh dude he's he's probably my favorite
actor now like he can like do any role yeah I love
E's the hawk you're in a difficult position I get
it I would do anything I had to for my family so
that's what I'm doing yeah but you were prepared
man come on Danny you can't desert us like this
haven't you been picking up watch me we've all
been deserted everyone's being deserted make her
Your [Music] Leader what I would like all of you
off of my property oh boy we're not going anywhere
till you give us what we need oh my God he's
going to shoot you dude this guy's been waiting
for an excuse to shoot [Music] somebody oh [__]
that's right Put the gun down all right we'll find
another way to the hospital there is no other way
besides he's not going to shoot us uh sounds like
he's going to shoot us what is going on they just
want to scare him away but also like I would not
resort to this hold on I get out of the way I'm
trying to reason with him he's white I can talk
to him in white people terms all the roads are
blocked we're in the middle of God knows where
there's no one else around I have no idea idea
what I am supposed to do it's kind of the point
I am a useless man and that is the point of the
movie what would you do if it was your family
that's what I'm doing it's the only thing I can
do just kill them Kevin Bacon please help my
son they did it it was them for sure
yep definitely th% it just takes enough
screaming I'm your mom now yeah seriously
bonding experience he took the money oh my
God this guy Jesus Christ he took the money God
oldfashioned barter system was to be expected at
some point wow dog hey I got another tidbit
for you free of charge if you want it it's a
Koreans behind all this who makes you say that
just trust me the Chinese one of them oh God
right underneath the right underneath the whole
Glory baby the Chinese one of them you know what
those Asian countries they're all the same big
drone dropping these everywhere it means death
to America so we're thinking Iranians I remember
hearing something on NPR once about their cyber
capabilities pledge Drive baby NPR before the
phones went out I heard from a friend of mine in
San Diego about a similar event drones dropping
pamphlets except they were in Korea or Mand any
like I said he couldn't tell which seeing as he
did four tours in Iraq he sure as sure would have
known if it looked like that we made a lot
of enemies around the world maybe all this
means is a few of them teamed up ah cool we've
created Unity yeah the we were here to do all
everyone United against us we're the coach of the
world Man United States have United all the other
countries that house that's got to be where she
went oh she sees Rosy's body I don't know but
she was looking at that house earlier no matter
how far this thing goes I need to know that we're
good cuz if what just happened here is happening
everywhere we need to get to that bunker Danny
told us about and we need to get there now what
are you talking about he's saying that you need
to team up and survive together had a sneaking
suspicion but I wanted more information first
all SIDS were there sure but I whole movie holding
out on his man it would have made more sense if we
were on the brink of an allout invasion but this
I didn't think we'd actually let something like
this happen I thought we were smarter than
that n no there's not that much order in the
world cuz my primary client works in the defense
sector I spent a lot of time studying the cost
benefit analysis of military campaigns go there
was one program in particular that terrified my
client the most three-stage maneuver that could
tople a country's government from within dialogue
they give him first stage was isolation disable
their communication and transportation ation make
the target as deaf dumb and paralyzed as possible
that's us yep setting them up for the second stage
synchronized chaos terrorize them with covert
attacks and misinformation yep without a clear
enemy or motive people would start turning on each
other that just happened hey we're all a part of
it done successfully third stage would happen on
its own Civil War oh War that's what I just no you
guessed that I just heard in my head you thought C
and I said soil War s this program was considered
the most coste effective way to destabilize
the country because if the target nation was
dysfunctional enough it would in essence do the
work for you America is doing it on itself yeah
cuz we're just that dysfunctional can't agree
about [__] whoever started this wants us to
finish it so you're like purging Society yep
essentially you know forced upon you from the
outside 1 hour pedal to the floor my dude oh is
the house over there the same one with the Panic
Room the one you said he'd sleep
[Music] through cool thought this
movie would hold out on us show this
in some like [__] news report yeah
everything was returned swiftly to
normal after some random technical
glitch I bet these guys own all 10 seasons
of Friends in a special Blu-ray collector's
pack yeah what do the Thorns have let's
go she broken glass means nothing to
this [Music] camera oh my God you're just in
here having the best time straight chilling
this is like buddy the elf's greatest dream
this is what paid for this entire mov here
all the products on this table I have the set
engraving for poptarts and Reese's and Ocean
Spray wow good touch oh I would love to build
one of these oh my God the Thorns got it hooked
up oh my God they got jugs of ant Jima they
don't make ant Jima no more one problem with
these basement you know apocalyptic ones they're
always gross whoa hey elevator radiation levels
where are these reports coming from just
going to get friends oh my God they have
friends puffy come on find the DVD byebye
birdie Center Stage they like tab Gilmore
Girls friends frays it's alphabetized got at the
final episode she found a DVD physical media this
the real message of the movie is buy all your
favorite films on DVD or shows weird message
Netflix this is just one long ad for them bringing
DVDs back to Netflix and then they
scratched the DVD for anyone who
hasn't finished friends is a real bummer
about to spoil the whole show for a you
know please end right here please end right here
please tell me they did it tell me they did it yes
yes I love it and that was the name of the
Final Chapter right chapter five was called
the the final one or the last one I think
so wow damn killing it well Rachel got off
the plane oh just spoil it for everyone I got
off the plane I mean I figured the whole movie
Out can't believe I did it you did it dude you
should write movies like this for Netflix where
you'll get paid and residuals and all that other
good stuff now but you know when you are dealing
with an apocalypse like this yeah sometimes it's
scared to go outside yeah having to forage for
food and things yeah sometimes you just want
that food delivered fresh to your doorstep
yeah in a way you could stockpile and hold on to
for any occasion no matter how simple nor world
rending we have to interrupt this broadcast
with a special message from myself Aloha
reject Nation Greg here so many of you guys know
most of my days are a couple of hours of filming
and then most of the time it's dedicated to like
editing and a bunch of other computer work often
accumulating to like 10 to 12 hours a day and
on top of that comfort food is like my life's
biggest Vice but as many of you also know working
out and and getting healthier has been a massive
component for me this year in particular so in
this Whirlwind I have found myself a perfect Ally
for quick healthy meals America's number one meal
kit a meal kit that I have subscribed to prior to
ever agreeing and working with them so yes this
is a genuine testimony and that is of course for
hello fresh and hellofresh is in just about ease
about bringing health and flavor to your doorstep
in this holiday season forget about the stress of
planning meals for your health conscious friends
friends like me who will breathe down the back
of your neck being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so with hellofresh I'm looking forward
to hosting holiday dinners that are not only
delicious but also cater to Healthy Lifestyles
best part the variety it is incredible I'm
pescatarian so they have these delicious meals
just like Dijon onion crunch salmon over lemon
broccoli spaghetti and from my more plant-based
days the vegan Maple carrot power bowls they
aren't just meals they're culinary Adventures I
learned the word culinary during a long day the
last thing I want to do is spend a while cooking
and that's where helloof Fresh's 15minute meals
are a life saver they're quick nutritious and Oho
tasty perfect for my non-stop lifestyle so why
not join me in making this holiday season both
health conscious and delicious with hellofresh
with over 45 recipes and seasonal add-ons to
choose from every week there's always something
new to try and here's something to cheer about go
to hellofresh.com reject free and use code reject
free for free breakfast for life is that accurate
that sounds way too good to be true there's no way
that can be true go to hellofresh.com reex free
and use code rejects free for free breakfast
for Life One breakfast item per box as long as
your subscription is active tag your hellofresh
creations with # hellofresh piic and at hellofresh
and let's cook up some fun and healthiness reject
Nation remember it's America's number one meit
all right thank you hello fresh John before we
talk about anything let's create some categories
here o chapters just like in the movie yeah yeah
I want to make sure we talk about every okay so
let's go over the ending okay and then uh what
what else do we have to interpret or do should we
try to find meaning of uh okay so just what was
really going on yeah what is this apocalypse what
other things happen that we should dissect the
meaning of animals Animal symbolism yes definitely
oh God it's going to be hard what else we got uh
we got color symbolism jeez racial subtext oh
yeah man this is going to be a tough one damn
you know class commentary and uh go performances
performances tone Direction and cinematography
yeah yeah okay all right let's go with the ending
one first ending ending explained yes watch us do
this without any research just just absorbing
what the movie's giving us uhhuh we can do this
ending explain all right so Rosie goes down to the
rich man's bunker uh and then finds the friend's
DVD watches the last one I think there's multiple
meanings here guys get ready for this Greg's about
to sound so smart smart Greg incoming Rachel got
off the plane I think the wife got off the plane
okay I think wife survived that's it's a simp yes
it's an Easter egg of sorts it's it's just such
a weird ending to end on her getting the DVD cuz
there's so much emphasis on it okay let's try to
be sincere for one second John there is this like
there is this emphasis on uh when they find Joy
through certain forms of escapism right and she
I mean the daughter has this whole thing about
like world sucks but I like these friends people
and it's the way a lot of us describe the show
Friends my favorite show of all time and I would
describe very similar experience that this this
girl uh describes friends being as then even when
um MERS Ali and Julia Roberts they're dancing it's
via through the form of art through the music
you know so I think that even in despite these
chaotic toerist times that they are living in uh
to put it lightly that their source of Happiness
can still be found in some form of art yeah I
would say I think that's maybe what the the the
choice to end on that specific note ultimately
is about like she finds a genuine smile in that
yeah in that heartbeat of a moment you know and uh
like she pigging out enjoying the junk food so and
but beyond that I think with ending on friends
which is an art firm trying to see this like a
third time where they find Art like I like how is
the music in that is there another moment well I
mean there are other things like she says that
like oh they love the pool I just want them to
focus on that then it's like forms of recreation
and like simple little things it's a record it's
dancing it's swimming it's being outside it's
finding your favorite show or whatever it might
be and yeah it's those little thing it's like
in a situation that is like asking you to find
impossible solutions to what seems like the
most insurmountable set of circumstances it's
the simple things whether it's a world rending
scenario or just personally intense Stakes
it's the little things that give us respit from
that that's a very solid point I think we have
explained the ending indeed friends communal
what have we got here friends people who have
become friends even though at first they were just
strangers to each other that's true and they're
all kind of you know inhabiting the same building
like in friends they don't you know sleep in the
same room but they're neighbors kind of if you
make the house an apartment building yeah you know
what I mean and then uh you know rich friends and
then uh uh uh Kevin Bacon is Gunther you know he's
down the road at the cafe fair enough he gives
there were six people at this home six members ofs
I think the show Friends has way more to do with
it than people realize it does it does I think
you're correct about that and then for a show
that was often criticized for being just only like
white folk yeah got a little bit more diversity
here that's right this was diverse friends this
was diverse friends is what we watched I'll be
there for you have that song playing over it when
the question posed at the very end with mersy and
Ethan Hawk was will you be there for me will we be
there for each other when all this [__] is truly
hitting the fan yeah and are you on the level with
me can I trust you will you be my friend that's
that's what I yep yeah it's beautiful man that
was good saying that's probably what it's about
right I think we have explained the ending and so
and you hear Julie Robert's voice outside who was
on Friends emphasize this enough yes we hear her
voice as uh as young uh Rose is sitting down to
watch the show so we can assume that she's going
to be found by her mother and that they probably
all will hold up in this Panic Room for as long
as the resources can go around I think they I know
that we didn't get to where they find her but they
see they see where the house is it is their house
the timer is set they are going back they say that
they need to go to the bunker I think it's safe
to assume that they will they all end up bunker
down there together and then fight over what we
watch on TV okay what was the name of the people
who were there in the house the ho the Thorns
the Thorns yeah where were where were they I
don't know they got out of Dodge maybe we we're
not explaining it see that's the thing is maybe
because they were Rich enough to already have this
off the books Panic Room maybe they had Panic Room
underneath the yes or maybe they went someplace
else even more secure they have like a private
island someplace and they got out early cuz like
you know maybe they gave Kevin Bacon a a heads up
you know because he was like Hey you know here's a
little piece of information for free your friends
the Thorns why don't you go check them out huh so
do you think Mahaw Ali was right we're moving on
in that category uh right about which thing about
him saying he was breaking it down for Ethan Hawk
uh gotcha gotcha of saying like this is what's
really going on this three-step thing you know
and the implication is that the United States is
doing it unto itself or we are being attacked and
this is this is their plan well no the message
I took from it is is if we follow these steps
we cut everybody off from everything and then we
create you know uh simultaneous chaos everywhere
then the people this divided nation of people will
will take care of the rest Naturally by you know
destroying and eating each other basically perfect
I love to hear you're so pent up here in the here
in these divided states that uh yeah they'll just
we'll take ourselves down you know all they got
to do is introduce a little chaos and then you
know the misinformation the Lea flits all that
stuff give us a million directions of where to
point the finger and then you know pretty soon
yeah we'll just all be Scavenging and and looting
and all that stuff wow wow and you believe that's
what was really going on I believe it he seems
convinced it seems convincing and it also doesn't
seem like it it's both to me it's like I think
logically speaking yeah it is some kind of you
know uh tech-based attack because of course that
that seems like a very Salient message we rely so
heavily on these interconnected things that we
don't fully understand the nature of that if we
were to be removed from them we would be many
of us quite helpless and uh and so yeah it's
like that seems like a very conscientious way
to take down you know a country or whatever it
is and you see the bombs going off so it seemed
relatively reasonable to assume that that what
he is saying is happening is probably the case
however you'll never know or you until it's over
in a situation like this I imagine you wouldn't
really know and so I think yeah that that little
piece of ambiguity suits it but it does certainly
seem like that three-step scenario he was talking
about yeah I mean a lot of the themes also seem
to about dealing with reality of the situation
yeah even right down to it's probably on the reac
highlights and I'm going to watch my words here
even right down to um the teen boy in the midst of
everything is still like oh I'm going to go look
at my phone and try to touch myself a lurk on this
girl here yeah yeah like but he can't ultimately
uh continue to do so um and so but again and you
know like even while they're dealing with stuff
and they're drinking and and vaping and whatever
that they're they still try to find like forms
of escap is and when so much of this is about
trying to face face reality deal with reality
the cigarette The Vape all those things yeah man
so um that's one one theme oh man this movie is
so multi-layered it's it's it's it's got you
know it's got some layers it's based on a book
is it I assume so uh didn't it say it was based
on a book it was adapted or something there was
some like line at the beginning yeah adapter for
the screen or something like that there was some
some text there that implied based on something
yeah uh okay so we have that themes that's some
good themes yeah well and yeah and at what point
do you accept that the I I think that was a good
theme that they brought up the idea of like oh
is there a shadowy cabal of people who run the
world or is the scarier alternative that no one's
in control and all these things all these tenuous
agreements we make collectively that form Society
are that are ten and can be rattled at any moment
animals animals yes well for me I was thinking
about I mean I've tried saying it but I would
get so caught up in oh my God I feel like there's
important lines happening here yes so I need to
kind of talk while also try to absorb lines to
me brings it back to the uh roots of Earth for
us sure like when you when you think about like
the land of animal there like this should be a
planet that is an humans are just another part
of the animal kingdom but we have created this
distinction between humans and animals yeah
and through this distinction we have created
metropolises and technology and all these things
that have slowly corrupted and destroyed our Earth
in turn destroying the land of our um our uh our
neighbors animals and that's at least what I was
taking from it that was my interpretation of why
there was all this emphasis on animals and messing
with migration and stuff like that um so yeah I
don't quite get what deer means I don't understand
I don't know the actual Association of like what
does what does horse symbolism mean what does deer
mean let's do some deer symbolism deer symbolism
in many cultures the deer is a symbol of Spiritual
Authority during the deer's life antlers fall off
and grow again and uh the animal is also a symbol
of regeneration and Christian imagination the deer
is a symbol of piety devotion and of God taking
care of explain to me what it means in the context
of this movie John well all the deer and that
is one of the more overtly Supernatural feeling
elements of this movie that does flirt with that
tone I guess to me it's perhaps the animals sort
of uh maybe recognizing like Hey we're already out
here we're away from the city we're in much more
of Nature's Domain than man's domain even though
you have this fancy house here maybe they are
recognizing like hey you're kind of being returned
to our community in a sense we are sort of here
to recognize you and I feel like the daughter both
of the daughters are the ones they seem to most
communicate to so maybe there's like a a mother
nature thing both of the daughters though they
have very different Vibes and functions within
the story seem aware of and kind of attune to
things in a way that other characters aren't
or it seems like they're at least not trying to
delude themselves the way other characters are
so maybe it is that they have that direct link
to the fauna around uh you know in some kind of
spiritual kind of sense I mean that is that is
the point at which the movie does get the most
sort of abstracted and and you go like okay is
this this must really be happening given how this
movie has presented itself thus far so there must
be like a hundred of deer here uh so that part of
it is is interesting to me I'd be curious to hear
about people's interpretation of how overt that
symbol is used but you also have the flamingos
you know which uh which I don't know if there
is a direct Flamingo symbolism I'm way ahead of
you there oh what you got what you got symbol
of beauty Grace and a sense of otherworldliness
the presence of flamingos in the story serves as
a contrast to the chaotic and unsettling events
that occur they represent a connection in nature
what I've been getting at here a reminder of the
Tranquil world that exists beyond the chaos of
human existence again bringing us back stripping
us away from these man-made Creations yeah they're
just here going all I really that's what every
animal sort of means here in some sense I mean
yeah especially the more unless you're in a story
that is very removed from the trappings of modern
life especially modern Western life uh yeah feel
like there's always a little sprinkle of Spanish
speaking woman uh well I mean that'll be another
thing is is our I I guess that's a heightened uh
version of our inability to communicate in a
crisis scenario and you can't help but imagine
maybe if Ethan Hawk had kept his head H you know
he could have been the person we all hope to be
not just the person that we think we would
be given the kind of attitude his character
displays much of the time and lead up to that you
would expect him to be the guy to be like get in
and we'll figure this out but at the same time
he's getting overwhelmed she's I I would love
that one of those things where I was sitting there
going man like a Spanish speaker in the audience
probably has like a little nugga of context the
rest of us don't and uh and I think that's cool
I think that that at least yeah zero in on the
fact that a chaos situation like this there will
be yes literal language barriers but in the more
figurative sense there will just be communication
breakdowns when everyone is in a panic and people
are going to handle that situation sloppily
that's part of the Controlled Chaos that they are
introducing here I guess it's also the start of
like the fear of the unknown yeah mhm yeah exactly
and I mean it it height it zeros in on some of
that xenophobia certainly not in the most doesn't
exist in this movie not in the most malicious way
but in a way and and what fear does to you and I
mean too yeah like uh I don't know there's this
was from an earlier point but there is a certain
amount of bargaining I feel like everybody in this
movie does where they're like no no no there's
somebody out there like someone's going to take
care of his there is an order there's a hospital
we can get to and it's you know everybody is sort
of getting how far does things need to progress
before you get to the point where you're like
well all we have is what we have right here in
front of us you know yeah yeah movie kind of
hits the nose on hits the nail on the nose head
hits the head on the nose nail when it comes to
you know the stuff like the electric cars and
um no they're saving the world me one you got
with the Tesla billionaires um it's okay it'll be
rivan in a few years from now but but I think it's
I think it actually spoke more to the point of I
just love how it was like the automated version
of the electric car well and that's a slight leap
because I don't think cars do that yet they they
they test that technology and that's not been
implemented yet for my understanding because it
uh like fully self-driving no driver intervention
or no driver intermediary just like fullon no they
usually need to I mean they I'm sure they can
uh but in order for them to usually operate you
need a human body in the driver seat in order to
do it yeah because there are just certain things
but I'm sure they can program it where they don't
need a body in there well they're they're doing
it now and the reason it's not been made consumer
is because they haven't been able to fully rectify
the machine's inability to account for certain
anomalies so it will still hit stuff so part of
me is like okay this is a bit of a fantasy because
they're not just selling Teslas that self-drive
but I mean it is the exact fear you have about
those aside from it just malfunctioning somebody
like maliciously using them to jam up all the
roads is like diabolical everything crashing
in on itself and that sequence was so was very
intense very intense and also with um yeah like
when Julia Roberts is spouting about of like
how we do these things thinking we're making
a difference when we're not and that is us in a
nutshell and I was I was just listening to um John
Oliver's uh um segment about chocolate oh and I
had no idea just the amount of child labor that
goes into the production of our chocolate industry
and yeah that was quite eye openening I've been
very blind to this and I I love chocolate so I
was like let me buy as much chocolate as I can
before I finish this video before my guilt kicks
in and I stop buying chocolate any well I have a
year supply of chocolate it would just be a waste
a waste now so I should at least starving kids who
would love to have that chocolate I should at
least finish this chocolate you should or else
those poor people they're their hard work will go
to away yes you don't want to spit in the face of
all that hard work cuz they just get compensated
with the joy of knowing that you're enjoying the
chocolate make me question myself though like
oh maybe I shouldn't buy chocolate anymore holy
[__] I have to only buy very specific ethical
and probably quite price but even to that point
though it guys get to a point where even they
there's only so much even for the most ethical
of companies there's only so much mandating they
can do to ensure that like the way how through
the process of this to this to travel to this
that their chocolate is of the purest non child
laboring chocolate you they they've even had it
covers that like they even they've had to there's
only so much they can do to ensure for the most
ethical ones uh and and so my point being is that
with what this movie is talking about you know
that what perhaps what we think we're doing as
the real contribution to change is is truly not
enough that the impending doom of it all because
there's their environmentalism talks here uh I
think this whole thing of world decaying in on
itself is very much an environmental allegory in
a lot of ways there's a lot of different things
they're talking about but at the end of day it
keeps coming back to like it starts off with our
character of Julie Roberts who is essentially
our main character saying she hates people but
in the end of it all when everything's stripped
down we will need to rely on each other the the
few who we can trust yeah cuz that's all you
have either way as people yeah yeah and that
is kind of like the nebulus of humanity I think
it was Darwin oh could be wrong here careful but
I'm going to say it it's up to you if you want
to research it I don't want your Pagan theories
that there are things about um I remember the
meaning at least is that uh it Humanity has
thrived through cooperation that's how we Thrive
so when you strip us down to our Bare Bones that
love is kind of in our DNA of cooperation that's a
love sentiment yeah it's a bunch of [__] I don't
like it at all [__] not in the real world not
out here in the Mean Streets not when the chips
are down and everyone's desperate um and let's
talk about performances um I loved I loved it
I love I mean it was like watching a play yes
I love Julia Roberts's work here it's been a
while since I've SE like I saw her in ticket to
Paradise with George Clooney and much as I love
watching my old celebrities fall in love what uh
you didn't love the movie I liked it a lot okay
all right I do I like I like romcoms I liked
it a lot good um for anyone who doesn't know
I I watch a lot of romcoms it's like I don't ever
react to them but I'll go through my pH where I'm
like watching nothing moram comes and and I love
that I quite enjoyed it it was a lot of fun it was
a little different too and and uh what's wrong it
hit me finally hit me where I recognized the actor
plays Ruth she's on that episode of Black Mirror
she's the second episode yeah the documentary one
yeah yeah there you go yeah Netflix keep it in
house don't pay residuals right that's how we
do it we stable of actors we don't have to pay
much and there you go always ways this is kind
of a Black Mirror esque episode very much um and
uh yeah so I think Julia Roberts was excellent
here showed the most growth yeah and a character
that that is not the most glamorous to take on
but requires a lot of subtle chops from an actor
yeah yeah she was excellent her and Ethan Hawk I
really believed as a couple I think Ethan Hawk is
absolutely excellent he's a fire in every role the
guy ever does yeah no matter what genre he really
is like a chameleon he's special he's he's a true
true Talent yeah cuz he's just so he just seems
so natural in any role he slips into yeah and
even here is like he's not the tough one in the
relationship ship oh that whole useless man speech
broke my heart and I was like yeah that's a lot
of us yeah yeah that's me all the time yeah it's
like I don't know and and early on he even says
that thing he like your mom's the tech whiz you
know I'm just a thing he's just a thinker guy yeah
loved his work Mersa Ali commands as usual sure
yeah um I do love the dire it smart it was smart
of the movie to not to create an immediate plot
of like a horrible of like a terrifying Airbnb
situation gone wrong right yeah get barbarian
with us get barbarian make you suspicious of
like what's really at play here is it going to
be about these people caving in on themselves as
the movie does lose sight of it's like a mediate
plot and become all about what's going on in the
world and commentary like it does not in the last
like hour it does just become about that it's all
symbolism and topics I guess we're all who we say
we are there's chaos happening all around I did
kind of wish the movie focus in a little bit on
how do you keep it about what's really going on
between the people in the house yeah and that
plot and then letting the commentary also coincide
with that versus let's really just make it about
what's going on out here yeah and Fun Stuff um
so yeah that was one part of it but the performan
has remained as strong as ever from beginning and
like everyone had chemistry the children writing
children I I think writing a like uh I don't
like to criticize a child's performance and B
I don't uh I I I often fluctuate on a criticism
of writing children because I I don't ever go
that's not how children talk because I don't know
children and and I don't work with children so I
don't really know like I think about how children
now as opposed to when we grew up uh they grow up
with cell phones and iPads that give them access
to um all kinds of media that would that might
make their the way they speak and their vernacular
and all that be much more um more advanced wide
ranging than how when how I grew up because of
the amount of exposure they have that I some
people think it limits one's capacity to learn
but at the same time it could also enhance one's
language just due to the amount of exposure they
have you know it makes a lot of things more second
nature and it is interesting because we live in a
time where you know you have the idea in your mind
from my you know from our perspective I'm sure of
like movies where kids talk like adults and it's
a Trope and it's and it's a precocious child yeah
but we also now live in a moment where kids or at
least younger and younger kids are able to speak
with more and more adult inflection and vocabulary
because of the vastness of the internet they have
access to and like yeah yeah I think you you said
something during the movie which I think is true
it's like you know it's hard to write kids partly
because you're probably drawing from kid talk
from when you were a kid which was probably a
while ago and now we live in a time where more
so I think than ever before just again because
of what the advancement of the internet and every
kid having an iPad or an iPhone is like yeah there
is a different it's not the same as precocious
child of yesterday year but it is like a different
tonality of of characterization I guess and
it is hard to nail down certainly and I mean
between the two I I think I preferred Rose to the
brother prefer the character yes yeah I thought
the we hear
audio doesn't matter doesn't matter
doesn't matter as long it's not on
the video um so yeah I I think the
the teen boy god what the hell is his
name it's definitely coming from in the computer
though what is this what is happening right now
yeah it's come from in the computer where is
it we're so late in the video it's on this
confusion is happening what's going on out there
John running it can't be uh I'm it doesn't make
any sense I'm just going to close out all of our
web Windows just close it all out shut it down
all right I mean there's only so many things I can
shut down now shut it shut it all down something's
playing on a loop it's Coy's voice from some other
earlier recording and I don't like it I don't like
to hear it nope I don't like to hear a vager
even if it's not in our our little record even
if it's not our headphones there's a tiny bit
I don't like any of it John it's bothering me
it's gone it's bothering all right cool let's
just keep talking we're fine it's gone we're
fine um so teen boy like while like very much
no depth at all to that character no not even
like an attempt at depth anti-de depth yeah he's
just that typical teenage he's a horny teenager
and like what else is there to and my sister's
a drag and I'm going to do everything I can to
not open up to her yeah yeah uh I didn't really
care for him uh but I weirdly found the writing
on him more believable just because of the cliche
of a teenage boy and I know what it's like to be
a teenage boy so even though I didn't behave like
that when I was a teenage boy I know known enough
teenage boys when I was teenager to get that
and uh and her like that that was my point of
of of like I can't sit here and tell you that
little girl wasn't believable because I don't
know what it's hard for me to wrap my head around
finding this little girl believable even though
I'm sure there are little girls out there who are
just as like hyper intelligent and precarious and
thought-provoking but I still liked her character
enough um to enjoy when she was on screen the
rose character the the young young one yeah I
I I guess I was maybe drawn to her a bit more
just because of how like strange her vibe always
was she almost reminded me of the little sister
from hereditary but like way less you know sort of
intentionally like oh this is a strange character
um but I don't know I I can't disagree with you
watching all the West Wing yeah it was great u
i mean her whole role is TV but I guess I kind
of only this Aon soring episodes I was like okay
this is a little too self-aware for my taste right
now yeah it's one of those things where I'm like I
don't necessarily put it Beyond a character like
this to have that level of observation or detail
or digging to her interests or whatever uh but
but that's a very writerly thing is to to name
check and just because you have Julia Roberts
being like you watch West Wing suddenly makes
that believable I guess um Ruth lamp shading a
little bit Yeah Ruth I liked Ruth I thought Ruth
I mean Ruth has to occupy the in between space
between the young kids and the adult adults and
uh and I liked the inter I mean I liked her
kind of vibe because she is the most uh the
most contrast from everybody else and I think that
her presence does interesting things for all the
different characters and yeah like I I like they
should have ridden her to be more seductive that
would have been more cliche so you could have
been more tempting to Ethan Hawk's character
yeah yeah we can turn this into knock knock
all of a sudden yeah I don't know like I like
that they flirted with that stuff and didn't go
there I like that she's like yeah he's not that
guy like he wanted to but he's not that guy uh I
liked things like that and I thought the interplay
between her and her father it's like even though
they are presented as a unit and you know there
is a very Us and Them between you know the two
pairs at first us or them damn Coral uh but I
thought that their tension between each other was
also a nice detail like a microcosm because of
course he's going to try and be managing her
expectations but also she's super sharp not
very complacent not likely to be the kind to just
accept whatever ever Comfort is being sold th% and
I mean you know in terms of all the characters
even though mersel Lai seems to have the most
concrete actionable knowledge of all of our main
characters she does seem to be the one with like
the most pragmatic attitude oh for sure um and I
thought her performance was uh was quite good too
so I don't know I I like that character I liked
her too I liked her too um everyone was really
good I thought the direction for for this was Sol
I actually really appreciated how we would see
actual outside world stuff instead of just only
keep like I I like the stories where they just
keep it contained in the house don't get me wrong
like I I'm a sucker for that and there's there's
one part of me that's like o I would have liked to
have seen that version yeah um but uh as it stands
I do think that this version that we got is pretty
compelling and I like the glimpses we would get
when they would be like on the beach or when they
would be on the road and the tesas are crashing
or when they see the outside world uh New York New
York City uh being destroyed feel convincingly cut
off from everything yeah yeah what's this movie
called again Leave the World Behind Leave the
World Behind sorry guys got to prep some footage
of simultaneously while talking cuz time crunch
oh we got Kevin Bacon too Kevin Bacon I think um
I think as Kevin Bacon has gotten I I wasn't a big
fan of Kevin Bacon when I was a kid okay but when
he's got as he's gotten older I have really grown
to like like the older Kevin Bacon performances
a lot the grizzled Kevin Bacon World weathered
Kevin Bacon is is a very good bacon I really like
I mean I've always I've always kind of like that's
a lie I've always liked Kevin Bacon but I've never
but I've especially liked him as he's gotten older
yeah I've been way more drawn to his like older
man performances yeah no because he brings a good
amount of like presence and and and yeah he can
show up and and it it feels like effortless but
also like he showed up and here you know it's
like you see him in that one shot and the movie
was compelling enough that I forgot about him for
a long time and even though he's only in a brief
sequence you know meaningfully uh I thought yeah
he still showed up and really kind of you know
fully committed to the kind of character who he
is and it's another aspect of the movie that is
certainly playing on and I like that this movie
played on and used but didn't get lost in not get
lost in but I don't I think it's it's appropriate
the way the movie used the sort of appearances
and the suspicion based on appearances you see
this guy and you're like okay of course this is
the guy who would be prepared for all of this and
of course for the two of us the the yepy city guy
and you know person of color out here on your
American flag doorstep you know maybe there's
some precariousness to this situation and uh it's
all together different feeling than you know when
they have the first meeting with you know Julie
Roberts and Ethan Hawk on the porch um but yeah
it's like without it manages to encapsulate a lot
of the fears and paranoia people have some that
are Primal and you know everybody has and some
that are more societal and some that are based
on yeah like cultural reservations and prejudices
and what notot yeah I thought it was great and I
think the dire so I think the direction overall
was excellent um I think there's a lot of like
really wonderfully shot sequences with um some
distorted angles and um some beautiful symmetry
rout and they managed to make and when they wanted
to they have to make play scene movies feel very
like cinematic and they did yeah and and I think
too when they did do sequences that uh were like
out on the road or whatever on the beach they
weren't like overshooting their load like it
felt very much like oh no they they know what
they're doing and this is really composed um music
I thought was excellent all the hearkening back
to like old school types of horror again I kept
getting like Twilight Z own flares from from it
uh really enjoyed that sound design flourish they
kept going for oh yeah sound design uh was great
too yeah um now I guess and the the needle drops
were were nicely contrasted for the most part now
I guess the one thing left to talk about is did
you like the movie I did I did it's it's a movie
I'm going to keep thinking about it it's a movie
that I can you give me that hard drive certainly
uh it's eced enjoyed in an immediate sense like I
I love the kind of movie that makes you sit there
and makes you sort of Wonder and puts you in the
paranoia and it feels like some big conspiracy is
going down and it's it's kind of neat to me that
a poit what is essentially a political thriller
about a terrorist attack or ostensibly is that
they cut to the moon at one point could be aliens
who knows uh but you know it's almost like a
political thriller without is interesting did you
did get the sense of like is it an alien invasion
yeah and it's fun cuz in that way it feels feels
like you're watching yeah an Apocalypse movie or
maybe an alien invasion movie or maybe some weird
the happening or whatever the house knock at the
cabin ended up being or something The Cabin
in the Woods yeah at the last house in the
cabin you didn't see that movie did no I haven't
but it's it's it's very I mean that one's more
I don't want that one's more religious based um
sure but but but at least from the trailer that
sort of like something is coming and there's
we're isolated and paranoid and this will be
kind of like a play maybe th% uh yeah so I I love
that kind of a Vibe and I like that this movie was
able to kind of keep you guessing as to like what
version of that are we watching I thought it was
appropriate where they landed to give you pretty
much the idea without fully confirming the idea
as we've sat here and talked about it it's sort of
uh uh uh calcifying in a pretty agreeable way with
me like initially the way where it ends I was
like oh it would be such a meme if they end it
right here but also in thinking about it I'm like
where else would I have ended this because it's it
it ends off in a way where part of you is like
well this could easily keep going you know but
I think at least tonally right now I kind of feel
satisfied with what it is I don't know exactly how
great I would say this is compared to what its
aspirations are but I don't think it's falling
very far short of its aspirations and I think
it's at least right now I thought it was pretty
good I'm going to see okay uh I haven't seen the
audience score yet okay right now it's got a 75%
on uh Rotten Tomatoes I haven't seen the audience
score okay uh I just want to get my opinion before
it's influenced by the audience score then I got
to change my entire point of view you update it
for the the crowd um but before we do that John
um here I'm creating this little fold what did
you think of Obama's producing I think he's trying
to uh you know have another career post presidency
yeah he's just got nothing now he's just out here
hustling trying to get a buck uh can you put this
in there yes of course I do think it's fun and
Charming that this is what they chose to produce
uh sure I think they produce other stuff um but
you know I think it speaks a little bit I I think
it it makes it puts it in a certain kind of lens
Obama is secretly telling us what to look out for
in terms of apocalpse I'm giving you government
secrets in this movie guys ex I learned this this
is text keep this close and learn from it uh I
I like I did like the movie I I enjoyed it and
um I was really into it like the first hour and
15 hour 20 minute Mark um and and I kind of did
you know sort of reveal already like where movie
started slowly losing me a bit was when it does
get bogg down more in the like everything stays
strong like solid Direction uh and the acting just
remains phenomenal the acting really I think helps
save a lot of that last hour for me um and while I
like the plot while I like the plot and everything
they're commentating on and and and stuff and and
sometimes the writing it's weird this movie is
one of those things where and it's all open to
interpretation it doesn't ever it's it's a a ver
it borders on becoming so expositional about what
its point is yes and then it also simultaneously
leaves you with it didn't quite tell you what
the point of the movie it didn't quite leave you
with the answer like I it it weirdly leaves you
in this terrain of exposition heavy and ambiguity
like at the same time and normally you don't get
both and and and it kind of leaves you with both
it it definitely is one of those movies that is
is doing a big contrast of like here's the plot
stuff and we're not going to spoon feed you the
actual story stuff like yeah and I and I think
that um I I could have used a little bit more
character driven narrative and not not lose sight
of that basically as where it kind of seemed like
it wanted to talk more about its ideas and then
it would remind itself the storytelling maybe
it's like it in the book I don't really give a
[__] we're talking about the movie all right
um that it would remind itself like we got to be a
little bit about the characters and the intensity
of what's happened to the characters uh like
everything with like Maha Ali going to the beach
and all that and the suspicions and then can they
trust each other and should they go should the you
know Julie Roberts and Ethan Hawk family should
they leave that was all so gripping to me whilst
doing the commentary of what the hell's going on
in the outside world like I was really enjoying
that and and then when it it it kind of brought
it back around to the scene with Kevin Bacon at
the end of like that immediacy and I was going
like I don't want M Le to die right now and nor
do want Ethan Hawk to die I don't want anyone to
get shot right now yeah totally like I hope none
of these guys get killed yeah um and it's not
like I ever stopped caring during the film but
I did start to feel its runtime at a certain point
yeah because I wasn't as invested in the character
narrative and I was finding it be more about what
it wants to talk about than it does want to tell
it through the lens of the characters and and
and I and that's the one thing about its focus
that I wish it it honed in on a little bit more
sure so overall I I really did like it like I
think there's a lot of craftsmanship to it that
I really enjoyed and you know for a stream for
in a day and age where where Netflix dumps like a
billion originals and and and whatever uh I could
see why this one stood out why this one became
a conversation uh not only because of what it's
conversing with this audience about but because of
its caliber of film making that it does you know
and like there is some real film making to this I
could have seen this as a theater experience you
know uh it doesn't feel like made for TV or made
directly for stream like I could have seen this
as a theater going exper I think they I think if
it was the theater they probably would have wanted
a more concrete ending they probably would have
wanted something that lays it out a little bit
better for its audience CU I could see a scenario
where some people feel like it's abrupt the way it
ends M where where you were able to cuz I didn't I
actually didn't think it was going to end when it
ended yeah whereas you were here going please let
it end now ple and it did and you were satisfied
and for me I didn't even get an inkling that it
was gonna end right there sure and I bet a lot
of people might not because because you watch as
like a bunch of got a low ass audience score that
is really that is really low Holy balls that is
a low audience score cuz you do watch a bunch of
things that are Loosely together like really
kind of scatter and then the movie ends it's
like they're all separated and they're all seems
like most people are pretty upset cu the ending I
bet cuz you get this quick 5 Seconds of scrolling
cuz you reach this Crescendo with all the deer and
you're like wow where you and and and something
happened with the son I guess he just did have
lime dis like a lime disease fast acting teeth
falling like like yeah you have these crescendos
of like they've run off into the woods and they
have this thing with the deer and she's looking
off at the beach and the explosions happening and
then Ethan Hawk and MERS they're all down the road
and there was Kevin B and the girl she's in the
Panic Room and uh and and yeah it ends at a point
where Everything feels I think innately kind of
like you're in the middle of something you know
and uh and yeah I think it's a thematic end point
that at least again to me right now I I'm not 100%
clicked in on but I'm like yeah I I appreciate the
The Quirk of this choice but I can also absolutely
see people hating that because it it gets you
to that point where you're like the only real
Direction you have is when Ethan Hawk and Marshall
Ali are leaving Kevin Bacon and they're like well
I guess we're just going to go back and we got
the medicine but the rest is all like you know
they're they're shouting still trying to find Rose
and Rose is off doing her own thing and like yeah
I can it just all it all feels like a bunch of
big things presented and then it's and then it's
immediately done you know yeah yeah I because I do
think that sometimes the I do feel like sometimes
the dialogue overall while again like so much goes
to the the directors especially I mean the actors
especially and then occasionally certain Choice
with the directors uh with the direction like like
um when like when Mah Ali is first giving this
the Spiel spiel about government agent defense
person and not saying who it is yeah and then
there's this little moment where he like put
puts his hand on her to stop her from getting her
drink and he gets a little more serious and the
camera Clos I'm like okay that was a good way to
make that more interesting yeah um cuz sometimes
it feels like they're it could be easy for some
moments when I pull out to go this kind of feels
like rambling pretentiousness sure sure sure
sure but I didn't ever fully get there uh with
any with any moment even though at times that's
what I meant by how it would ride this line where
I feel like I'm getting so told what this movie
is about and then going what is this movie about
exactly yeah yeah totally I get you cuz yeah it's
like you have to look at everything and assume
that most everything we were being given or shown
is important somehow and I didn't think we needed
the like as much as I felt like Kevin Bacon played
that role and this is coming from a from a man who
identifies as liberal or right I'm tell you this a
guy who identifies as liberal and and as funny as
I thought the moment was I thought it was really
funny um oh God the Korean or whates yeah as much
because this movie is produced by Obama yeah um
and Hollywood is full of a bunch of leftists you
know that's right Bry I think that you could
have Sav yourself a lot of when already a lot
of this is very much like leftist Scare Tactics
or whatever the [__] you want to call it right
as much as it's already there and so much of the
sentiment we obviously agree with right I think
cutting that out probably would have helped the
movie points get across a little bit because then
it's especially for that to be so close to the end
of the film yeah that does kind of cloud a lot of
I'm like because you don't need to like if if this
movie wants to be about its messages if this movie
wants to be about its commentary yeah to some
extent right and like I think doing something that
specifically obviously is going against you know
like your your your typical right-wing personality
um which I think was in the form of Kevin Bacon
at Le that's the way I saw it big American flag
or like the Korean or tiny you know [__] all
sorted out yeah it's meant to appear a certain
way at face value yeah yeah yeah so uh and I mean
I I think having that line excised probably would
have saved a little bit of blowback perhaps yeah
I'm curious cuz I mean you know maybe I'm read
more into it than I need to I I personally just
feel that way I'm I am I don't know I'd be curious
to hear people's thoughts I mean I think it does
draw uh the main I mean Julia Roberts and Ethan
Hawk I feel like are drawn as kind of a a yepy
neoliberal couple in a way that def isn't overt
as it is in like a get out but like in a way that
is clearly commenting on them as people and and
hey even though they might appear you know like
this you know uh both beautiful and also you know
like uh I don't know they they they get to the
dysfunction of their family later but you know
they appear as like you know a hip and with it
couple and he is very open and accepting of things
and and and all that and and yeah they're not
really all that they want to sell you that they
are uh and then yeah you have Kevin Bacon who's
like a much more bold-faced sort of yeah it's just
a thing you would expect from a character like
that and so the one is more subtle and the other
is not yeah because you have like Julia Roberts
who was pretty much admitting to like yeah I
had subconscious racism definitely factoring in
when I first met you like she's her character is
admitting to that and the whole I hate people in
general you know I hate people in general or even
like I I could see the Spanish-speaking Woman
as a fear of the unknown again with you know um
yeah like I I people coming into our country all
people but when I have to deal with them I don't
know what to do and I don't feel like we are as
the same as I would say in poite conversation or
whatever yeah yeah and you know again to hammer
in that point of the movie of we aren't really
doing enough yeah and we can say a lot and we
could think we're contributing but we're really
not yeah and there's so much we do every day that
is kind of meaningless and performative and all
that stuff yeah I think well when you when you
get to that whole thing at the end with Kevin
Bacon's character which is those little couple
lines uh it's like yeah a little a little much
it is a little I thought it was really fun I
like the delivery intentionally funny like I I
thought delivery was so good know yeah um but I I
do think that you you're already like pushing the
boundaries your political point of views here this
movie is very political it's extremely political
yeah and it's not and and it's not like without
that beat you wouldn't be able to communicate the
idea that the leaflets that Ethan Hawk finds you
know being you could still establish that the same
thing happened with leaflets printed in Korean
or Chinese or whatever uh and that it's all part
of a misinformation scheme without that little
character you know Nick of like oh yeah and he
doesn't care what the difference is sure sure you
know at first he seems so sure it's Korea and the
second someone's like are you sure he's like well
I don't know it could be anything which again I
I guess I'm I'm torn because it is funny and it's
like a real thing and it serves the moment in that
initially you think again oh this guy must know
and then it's like well he doesn't really no he
just has like a vague piece of context which
is about as good as you're going to get yeah
but yeah I mean at the same time it is one of the
more uh directly caricaturist is elements of the
characterization here yeah even though he's the
one who's a survival one he was the one who had
was ahead of the curb here and he helps out I mean
he does eventually take the money and give them
the kill even though but and I just think oh but
then taking a jab at that uh kind of negates like
like you're already painted this guy already like
not the greatest light yeah you don't need to do
like that additional stuff because we already
know what's better about Ethan Hawk and mshel
Ali being able to team up where clearly this guy's
not going to be willing to team up with y'all like
the contrast will be there whether we have that
yeah beat or not yeah man but um overall I liked
it overall I thought overall I really enjoyed it
and um it's a good time and uh maybe one day I'll
watch it again maybe it's no bird B s De maybe not
a movie I could not finish oh a movie I haven't
even started couldn't do it a I was like I'm going
to put it on and I was like 40 minutes in was like
I don't think I like I don't think this mov is
for me wow I'm excited now I check it out I did
not like the there was so much about it I really
didn't like it really yeah just kiding I'm bored
with it oh I have so many questions now as the
movie we'll leave you with um I think I don't
know stop 40 minutes in definitely question finish
it couldn't stand characters man couldn't stand
it that's fair that's fair like that felt like a
streaming movie to me for sure this felt way more
above that okay okay did it feel uh even though I
know people like Bird Box way more than like this
movie I was going to say did that movie feel very
high on its messaging did it feel very like we're
doing profound [__] over here in the bird bu I
don't recall thinking that I just remember really
not finding the characters believable and and to
me it was the characters I just didn't like the
characters okay good to know and I didn't think
the good actors um were enough to elevate it or
help me see past how terrible the characters were
Sandy didn't save the movie I don't remember who
that is Sandra Bullock oh yes the lead you did
not save it for me all right but what do you
guys think they'll Leave the World Behind leave
your thoughts down below appreciate y'all being
here um be sure to subscribe tell us who you're
voting for in the comments um um keep politics
out of this video but put it in the comments yeah
keep your politics out of who's your 2024 vote in
comeing this election year Woo which debate are
you looking forward to the most oh yeah in your
specific state you live in um what Third Party
candidate will you cast a vote for in order to
ensure that your vote doesn't really sway anyway
if you're the actual election if you're not part
of America what do you think about America leave
your thoughts down Below in the comments what have
you think thought about a recent presidency and
the one before that and the one before that leave
it all down in the comments below and whoever
replies to you make sure to reply back to them
and keep that conversation going yeah whatever it
takes don't even you don't even have to listen to
each other just keep spouting your own point of
view and uh fill that comment box I think as long
as you guys keep trying to convince each other
that you're the right one 100% right by the way
one of you is bound to be not wasting their time
shot it could be you is the patri of the day shout
out all right John pick a name uh pandemic Jones
pandemic Jones my friend merry Christmas you know
what Santa's giving you this year well what do
we know about pandemic JS what do we know about
he's giving you an inoculation what an inoculate
vaccination that's exactly what I was going to say
except not with such fancy terminology oh sorry
yeah vaccines inoculate you to various diseases
and or P high brow vernacular for my brain what
the hell was that that's Ebon or Scrooge of me
let me bring it down to the the street level
that's right you're getting the jab this year
my friend pandemic and you know what this one's
going to protect you against more than just what
everyone else is protected against you're going
to get V you're going to get protected against
you know um people's incompetence you're going
to get protected against uh herpes you're going
to get protected against uh it's like paying too
much for stuff at the grocery or any other store
it's a coupon really is what you're getting and
you're also going to get protected against being
taken advantage of at card mechanics just
whenever I'm about to finally insert you
just go andert you're going to be protected
against interruptions is what I hope you get
protected against Mr what you say inoculation
it worked did it yes it did guess I remember
the word now I didn't interrupt you then it's my
new favorite word yeah get inoculated baby Merry
Christmas PJ hope s or Jesus or somebody
gives you something special this year the
Jab